[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the world's worst youtuber joined by
the world's best youtuber
chris from 3c films how's it going hey
poopy doopy happy to finally be in your
home none of my
audience knows who you are but you know
i figured i'd go ahead and throw you a
solid and join you here
yeah none of my audience know who i am
either which is really good
so throughout this video we're going to
be talking about the most shocking
moments in the
comic book series the boys that aren't
really going to be in the tv series
or if they are they're going to be toned
down now obviously there's going to be
heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want anything rude then
get the hell out of here and go and
watch
one of three c's amazing amazing
mediocre videos now firstly i just want
to talk about becca's death
this was a massive massive point in the
comics and tv show
um it was obviously the way what it was
the big
moment in the the finale i feel of the
season two
episode eight and this was actually set
up
in the first season as well as the
comics now in the comic books
billy butch's entire motivation was to
basically get revenge for what happened
to his wife
we found out that black noir actually
raped her and because of this
she had a baby that burst out of her
stomach in the middle of the night
and he he woke up to see its eyes
glowing red and it floating above her
corpse with its umbilical cord still
attached to her
pretty nasty and i actually thought that
you know
this would i watched basically the first
season at a time before i used to binge
tv for my youtube channel i really got
to take everything in
and i remember sitting there thinking oh
yeah
his wife's dead this is very much in
line with the comics so at the end
of that season when she she came out
with the sun
i think whoa what's all this about
now what's interesting is that the
second season actually
kind of went back to the status quo in
that it had her die at the hands of
homelanders son
so you know we are seeing these moments
of
things sort of riffing on the original
source material
but they're doing it in a in a very you
know toned-down way
yeah i like that change that you know
it's still responsible for the sun and
whatnot i just yeah
i i don't think they could have made it
work with the with the baby popping out
and stuff like that because we had to
get to know becca
yeah exactly and there's a term in comic
books called fridging
which is basically where
yeah so it was good that she got some
backstory
i really liked her in this season i
thought she did a really good job
and you know i think it was a change for
the bear but it wasn't as shocking
no no you know we love the gore out here
it's speaking a
shocking going back to like the first
season here one of the most shocking
things that happens
right away to let you know this ain't
your marvel cinematic universe type show
you have starlight coming in joining the
seven
and then pants drop from the deep
telling her you know basically you want
to join this what you got to do
in the comics she had to do almost the
whole team half of them
with black noir homelander and i think a
train
how did you feel about them just
bringing it down to just one dick
well she really had to swallow her pride
in both
both instances i'll cut that out so i
don't look like a bad guy
and yeah i think you know what's
interesting about
the the comics in comparison to the tv
show is that
the the tv show has done a really good
job of making these people relatable
and you can kind of see the good side to
them almost
there was a brilliant moment in episode
8 where homelanders sat down with ryan
was just kind of going over what it was
like
when he was a kid and in the comics they
don't really have that everyone's a bad
guy
bar probably the deep in starlight and
queen maeve eventually
but that was a brilliant way in the
comics i feel of just setting up
instantly that
these people aren't heroes and you know
starlight if she wants to be in the team
she's she's gonna have to do a lot of
things not nice
uh and in in the tv show you know they
cut away from it
whereas yeah you even get a point where
yeah you just you just see some running
down her mouth
yeah exactly and huey watches that at
one point on a
on some cctv and it's a lot more a lot
more graphic
now speaking of toning things down i
think they did the same thing with 911
now in the comics the the heroes are
actually
responsible for quite a lot of deaths
they they kind of do the the plane crash
scene in this
in the first season but the comics
basically they caused um the brooklyn
bridge to be destroyed with
a lot of people on it and you know they
they
they were basically hand picked at the
last minute to help out on 9 11 as a pr
stunt for vote
and it just went to hell they were
completely useless whereas
in the tv show the plane crash scene i
kind of feel like that you know they
could have maybe saved the day at some
point if they hadn't destroyed the
control panel
whereas the comic the deep gets hit by
an airplane and you just realize these
guys then
they're not doing anything one of them
runs away as well
[Laughter]
and with some of these scenes it it's
not even a situation of it being so
graphic because i mean even earlier in
the year we heard that they cut out
a major scene that ended up showing up
by surprise
in the end of season two homelander just
jerking it off to the city saying
he can do whatever he wants something
like that with the 911 scene that could
just be a budget
budgetary thing because one thing
they've changed in the show
that uh is pretty eventful from the
beginning is that the boys
have the ability to access superpowers
whenever they want through some little
bot pills
and they're not doing that here whether
to save on money or the budget of how
nasty they get when they actually pummel
some of these guys i know huey
is the first to accidentally kill a suit
yeah and that was really gory as well
but it does feel very toned down and
one of the major things that i i
remember reading and thinking
that's a bit far was when homelander
gets sent photographs of
himself basically biting into a
screaming baby and ripping out its
intestines
i'm probably going to be using this
image as a thumbnail so i'll get
demonetized but
it i remember reading that and thinking
it was absolutely
horrendous and so far homeland has
not really done anything that extreme
and
neither have really any of the the seven
i don't think
black noir spoilers for the comics he's
basically revealed as the
as a clone of homeland he was the one
who bit the baby
and even though you know he likes to
carry around people's heads uh
like he's still not gonna go to this
extreme i don't think
i think things unless they have milk
exactly
yeah maybe he ripped it off a mother
that was
breastfeeding we don't know that would
be something i would like to see that
would be too
far but she's just sitting sucking just
grabs it
but the milk is always good yeah so
what about uh one of their first
missions that leads into probably what
their spin-off show is going to deal
with
the first mission the boys ever deal
with with huey is they go
towards like this teen titan group of
superheroes and you see they're just
having
an orgy party switching around and these
poor women are just being pummeled and
hurt i
i don't know if that's something we'll
see in the spin-off
no and the spin-offs actually rumored to
be the g-men as well
um which they basically a lot of the
side teams
bought capes for church and super duper
i think it is
all of those guys are like sex pests and
completely over the top
and some of the sex scenes especially in
that first volume
are very very taboo you when
if you go from reading the comic book to
the show you just be like yeah this is
really really
tame and i can't see that being included
at any point
now onto the g men themselves they're
basically a parody of the x-men
and the professor of that school is
actually abusing the children
which is really really messed up and
yeah i think
the entire school is basically set up
for him to
to get kids who want to be superheroes
so that he can abuse them
and it's so messed up um and they're
meant to be doing that as the spin-off
show
but i already know from the way that the
the show's been set up in the series has
that
it's not going to be that graphic and i
don't think they'll have any of that
really in the series i think it'll be i
have most
suggested that but even then i can't see
it being as graphic
and as black and white as it is in the
comics and which
probably for the best especially with
how cuties is getting received right now
yeah and even in the comments it's like
every superhero has a sex
fixation i know there's one technique
who like bangs a cup of coffee when his
therapist is out of the room which is
like
so odd burns himself but in this one
they throw in different uh types of
fixations like i mean a storm front for
one was a nazi
was married to the lead of vaught yeah
exactly and that was probably more you
know stormfront was pretty bad but
compared to how
the the comic book character was i would
still say she was quite toned down
and there's also recently the um when
they've been discussing season three
eric kripke the the show runner has come
out and said that the gay sex scene
between
soldier boy and homeland i won't be in
the season either
so i think we are really getting the
notion that they're just cutting back
all the sex and especially that first
volume
was i remember reading it next to my
wife
and i tell you what she was looking
thinking what the hell is this guy
yeah i can't believe i married him
anyway that's the video here's the the
graphic novel so you know that we read
them and didn't just wikipedia
if you enjoyed this video nice little
quick quick one
and uh please give us a thumbs up make
sure you go check out chris's channel
it's a lot better than mine
no it is up to date on all the movie
news everything you need to know
whereas i tend to just spend four hours
talking about a little easter egg in the
background of a scene
so yeah i break paul's balls but he's
got a great channel here i might call
him poopy doopy but that's just because
he
has a ferrari a tesla all this big
mansion house this right here hundreds
of [ __ ]
pups and a real life infinity gauntlet
yeah guys but yeah thank you for having
me all paul really appreciate it and i
gotta have you on my channel soon but
just like a cameo appearance i'm not
giving you a full video that's fine
and hopefully this wasn't as
disappointing for the people who've been
wanting this collab for so long but uh
yeah go check out 3c films if you want
something else to watch after this i've
just done a
season three boys breakdown yeah check
it out and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you